with games like sea of thieves halo wars
- and crackdown 3 we've got quite the
year ahead of us on Xbox one these are
all the Xbox one console exclusives
confirmed for 2017 so far
rise and shine combines elements of
bullet hell shooters and puzzle
platformers in a world filled with video
game references Halo Wars 2 is a
real-time strategy sequel to 2009's halo
wars that follows Captain cutter and his
crew as they face a strong enemy brute
faction called the banished gone home
developer Fulbright's next game is
Tacoma a mystery game set in space
platformer cuphead pairs run and gun
gameplay with a distinct 1930s cartoon
art style and plenty of boss battles
crackdown 3 is an open-world action
adventure game that has you stopping
crime in a futuristic city where
everything is destructible a rerelease
of 2005 action strategy game phantom
dust is coming to Xbox one complete with
play anywhere compatibility sea of
thieves is a pirate adventure game with
a shared world for you and your crew of
friends to explore whether you're
looking for loot or trouble state of
decay - is a multiplayer zombie survival
game featuring an open-world environment
and co-op gameplay with up to 3 other
players there's still time for more Xbox
one console exclusives to be confirmed
for 2017 so let us know in the comments
what other games you think will come out
this year for more on all things Xbox be
sure to stick with GameSpot
[Music]
you